Oh bad guys to kill I only have 12
bullets so you're gonna have to share
it's the mask on my voice
ladies and gentlemen don't swallow
promises gets worse for you big boy
I'm touching myself today hey everybody
it's Charlie if you remember the test
footage that Ryan Reynolds leaked at
Comic Con a couple years ago for the
Deadpool movie before they actually
greenlit it and turned it into a real
thing the same thing just happened for
the animated series you might recognize
some of the dialogue for that this is
basically like a test trailer that
titmouse animation studios released when
they were trying to win the project from
Marvel like they obviously had Donald
Glover and his brother writing and
producing this series that's a
completely separate thing the animation
studios in Hollywood were competing for
the job to like we can do a really
awesome job the people behind it
actually gave a very specific shout out
to Rick and Morty so I'll explain the
connection to that too
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's gonna be so much
between Deadpool and infinity war
dropping it's gonna be crazy I know it
looks a little unfinished but that's
just because it was proof of concept for
Marvel like they were saying hey this is
what it would look like if we animated
it they had to come up with cool ideas
for what the animation might actually
look like now they actually didn't end
up winning the bid Marvel ended up
picking Floyd County Productions which
is the studio that produces Archer so
I'm assuming that it wasn't gonna look
exactly like Archer most of you have
probably seen at least a little bit of
Archer it looks vastly different from
this lot of your eyes are amazing Archer
I mean not compared to your tits but so
I think the animation looks fine but
obviously you probably picked up on a
couple of the easter eggs like they
basically clipped a lot of dialogue from
the original movie into a couple
specific scenes here like I'm touching
myself tonight and usually I don't say
this but don't swallow
[Music]
I've never said this but don't swallow
Oh
I'm touching myself tonight so it wasn't
like they had Ryan Reynolds doing new
dialogue for this but when they tweeted
this out like I do they announced the
cancellation news in Donald Glover
posted that fake script just sort of
meta commenting on the whole situation
the animation studio tweeted this out in
tagged Ryan Reynolds in it like hey are
you game are you down for this like they
still wanted to get back on the project
because obviously Marvel's gonna be
shopping the TV show around now so
whatever ends up happening it probably
won't be titmouse they deleted their
tweet Marvel probably asked them to take
it down and if you've been saying Disney
has actually been going around policing
the content here that's in this so it's
not because Disney owns Fox now and they
sort of own all this Deadpool content
it's because Marvel owns the TV rights
to Deadpool which is a really weird
situation I know there's a lot of
confusion when they got to use
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch during age
of Ultron but we got Quicksilver during
Days of Future past there was a Marvel
TV development executive that sort of
explained that the reason they were
allowed to do a Deadpool TV show that
didn't have anything to do with Fox like
it wasn't led by Fox it was Disney
Marvel doing a Deadpool TV show shopping
at to a Fox Network was because of the
terms of the contract when the Deadpool
character was signed over to Fox way
back when they license all the Marvel
characters that they have so it only
gets more complicated from there but for
the most part Disney and Marvel still
have access to most of the TV rights for
a lot of the Fox characters not the
movie rights that's really what Fox has
but obviously Disney is buying them so
it's gonna be a non-issue really soon
but if you guys didn't know what's going
on here he's actually fighting gorilla
man I think that's who this character is
supposed to be there's only one gorilla
that talks in Marvel Comics his name is
gorilla man I know very imaginative he's
basically their version of Gorilla Grodd
and he actually crossed over with
Deadpool in Deadpool team-up number 889
they were both put at odds by Borgia
Omega which is a character from the
gorilla Man comics to save lucrezia
borgia
he was trying to get them to fight each
other but then they ended up teaming up
by the end of the title so it'd
basically be like the flash team
up with gorilla grodd which is kind of
funny because the last couple of months
in the flash gorilla grodd has been
trying to steal the Speed Force from
Barry so he's actually been a pretty big
comic-book character in the current
flash comics but if you were still
confused about what's going on with this
Deadpool TV series Marvel still has the
rights they'll eventually shop it around
to some other studio when they figure
out what they want to do with it it
might go to the Disney streaming service
if you read that Donald Glover Mehta
script obviously it's not the actual
script for their finale is just him sort
of commenting on why he thinks that it
got cancelled in all the things that
Marvel had a problem with Stephen Glover
his brother who was sort of Co producing
and co-writing the project with him
actually tweeted out that they really
were going for a Marvel Rick and Morty
series where Deadpool was just
commenting on everything from pop
culture to comic book characters
internal stories it's basically what the
character of Rick does they do a lot of
send ups of sci-fi tropes through the
Rick Sanchez character so that's kind of
how the Deadpool character operates
which is why when I initially heard
about the Deadpool TV series I was like
maybe they'll try to use him for some
Rick and Morty fun but come to find out
that's actually really what they were
going for behind the scenes yeah putting
you'll get it when you're still actively
dating in your 40s with cold
indifference you beheaded and when he
says that Taylor Swift was the last
straw they actually did an episode
making fun of Taylor Swift we'll never
find out what was in that actual script
but apparently it pissed Marvel off but
like he says it was the last straw it
wasn't the only reason why they decided
to take the project away from them and
that's basically what happened it was
Marvel taking the project away from FX
and Donald Glover because Donald Glover
has a development deal at FX he's like
their golden child because they love
Atlanta so much he wants so many awards
for that series in FX does really weird
stuff like Legion so they were probably
cool with whatever they were going to do
it's really Marvel that sounds like it
wasn't comfortable with what the series
was going to be so no worries he'll be
resurrected again somewhere but I
wouldn't expect to hear anything about
that till like way later this year maybe
something at Comic Con
maybe something next year it's probably
gonna be a while like will
probably be watching the x-force movie
either next year the year after that
before we get to see a new Deadpool
animated series they're shooting the
x-force movie in October so I don't know
if they'll be able to turn it around
fast enough to release it by the end of
next year because it usually takes at
least a year in post-production to
finish a really big movie like that and
it will be a big team up movie with the
Deadpool characters but I wouldn't be
surprised if they opted to release it
Valentine's Day like they tried to
release Deadpool - but then had to push
it during 2020
so we'll post updates on x-force as we
learn about it but obviously that's what
Deadpool - is setting up like we're
gonna call our new team x-force we're
gonna form a super duper [ __ ] group we
need them topic morally flexible and
young enough to carry their own
franchise for 10 to 12 years because
it's Easter weekend they sort of
released a couple Easter promos Ryan
Reynolds posted this picture is sort of
like a Where's Waldo
Easter egg hunt with the Deadpool of Fox
characters but a couple of Easter eggs
in here so like you see some of the new
x-force characters mixing with the x-men
characters this seems like it's probably
happening outside the x-mansion where
they're all either having picnics or
they're all fighting each other so like
you see negasonic and Colossus hiding in
the bushes down here you see shatter
star he's actually being played by Lewis
tan if you guys didn't know who he is he
was the person from iron fist he's
actually pretty badass you see Wolverine
up here you see Jean Grey and Cyclops
you see magneto up here you see storms
standing on top of this 18-wheeler
that's being driven by blind al
there's Jubilee right next to them
there's this funny Professor X
wheelchair picture this looks like it
could be the McAvoy version there's
cable and Deadpool up here in the middle
but there isn't meant to be a special
particular Easter egg here is just meant
to show you like a bunch of x-men
characters crossing over with a bunch of
Deadpool characters for those of you
asking about new trailers there'll be a
new Deadpool or trailers soon there'll
be more Avengers infinity war real soon
- I don't know about the other big stuff
that's coming up there might be a Star
Wars trailer March Madness is sort of
shutting down the final four is tonight
they'll probably be some footage
dropping during that then the national
championships are on Monday night so if
any footage is going to be dropping any
time
soon definitely on Monday if not later
tonight whatever ends up dropping I'll
totally do a video for it but leave all
your requests in the comments below
there's a new flash promo in a new
Dragon Ball super promo that I'll be
breaking down later tonight so look out
for that stuff what you wait for
everything click here for the Deadpool
trailer again and click here for brand
new infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]